on revient avec booba scène sur la
teneur de ces débats ils ont commencé et
tout à l'heure à 15 heures effectivement
sophie les débats ont commencé dans les
alentours de 15 heures ici au palais du
luxembourg et continuent et continueront
jusqu'à environ minuit minuit et demi
pour cette première journée des débats
autour de ce texte sur la loi
séparatisme ce texte qui avait été voté
déjà en première lecture à l'assemblée
nationale et qui fait son entrée ici au
palais du luxembourg dans un contexte
assez tendu un texte qui divise à gauche
qui gêne à droite dans un contexte assez
tendu politiquement comme socialement en
france je vous rappelle la polémique
autour de ce financement de la mairie
écologistes à strasbourg pour la
construction d'une mosquée ou encore la
déclaration d'audrey pulvar à la
candidate ps à la région ile-de-france
pour les régionales ou encore bien sûr
cette déclaration du syndicat étudiant
l'unef concernant des réunions non mixte
c est dans ce contexte assez tendu que
débutent ces discussions au sénat les
républicains eux ont annoncé qu'ils
continueraient à s'opposer contre ce
projet de loi comme leurs confrères bien
sûr à l'assemblée nationale elle avait
fait déjà le sénat qui est
majoritairement à droite bien sûr entend
bien de se positionner sur des principes
clairs comme la lutte contre le
séparatisme alors que de son côté le ps
a déclaré que ce texte était
déséquilibré qu'il souhaite lutter
contre l'islamisme politique et bien sûr
en évitant toute surenchère
gouvernementale le ps qui a d'ores et
déjà annoncé une motion de censure
préalable je vous propose d'écouter le
ps ainsi que les républicains tous la
motion préalable qui a été présenté par
le président du groupe patrick kanner
qui tend à faire la démonstration que ce
texte n'est qu'un patchwork de mesures
certaines d'ailleurs sont utiles mais ça
ne fait pas un grand texte comme celui
que nous attendrions et il fait
l'impasse sur toutes les dispositions
qui pourraient être utiles pour faire en
sorte que ceux qui s'éloignent de la
république aujourd'hui y reviennent et
reprennent confiance dans les grands
principes qui sont les nôtres celles
d'une république dont la devise est
liberté égalité fraternité
moi je crois que notre volonté c'est de
réaffirmer des principes qui fondent
notre république
bien sûr le principe de laïcité et je
crois que nous avons essayé de
l'expliquer de le faire entendre une
forme de respect encore une fois de ce
qui fait le ciment de des valeurs de la
république
alors vous l'aurez compris c'est un
projet de loi qui divise la classe
politique française mais qui divise
également la société est française
depuis son adoption en première lecture
à l'assemblée nationale elle les
chrétiens de france ont monté à
l'offensive jugeant cette loi
discriminante et stigmatise stigmatise
entendu les sénateurs de droite ont
déclaré qu'ils tiendraient compte et
prendre en considération ces
déclarations ce plaidoyer des chrétiens
français
effectivement pour pouvoir revenir sur
l'assouplissement notamment des
obligations administratives et
comptables des associations religieuses
en france voilà dans quel contexte
débute cette lecture et ses débats ici
au sénat autour de cette loi séparatisme
merci beaucoup bassam
et bien en direct du sénat